this one's supposed to get great
be great this episode isn't that one i'm
supposed to get great yeah that's what
everyone says it's like this episode
what else is this 1919. this is where
i'm supposed to get great the one this
is the great one this is from here on
only top tier episodes
you're responding quite sarcastically
it's something that i'm being serious
about no i think this is the point where
people are like just wait just wait till
the end of season one it starts to
really really crest into something
amazing not to say it hasn't been quite
lovely and enjoyable so far well let's
see full length watch alongs over our
patreon for gravity falls along with a
bunch of other shows that we cover as
well and if you could leave a like that
would be amazeballs
and thanks to the boys of prep for
helping us out of this down let's see
what's going on
kids come quick
i need you to laugh at this with me he
was cute as a button and always your
friend little tid to the eon
oh no come on down the little gideons
tend to telepathy opening soon at this
location
no
the only way gideon's taking over the
shack is by breaking in and stealing my
deed
oh no 41. oh heavens to patsy
gideon shoot him once i steal that deed
you'll never see the mystery shack again
good luck bucko is there no lawyer in
gravity falls
i want to have the mystery shack safe
isn't the one place i'll never find it
my brain your brain isn't as safe as you
might think stanford pines this is the
last straw it's time to unlock the
journal's greatest secret
now that sounds like some bad news for
all of us that sounds like a doozy
it's the time for a gideon voice-off
oh no here we go oh your voice is
sweeping mine's sweet or like georgia
peach tea you pass through my water
please hey i'm sorry giddy
give me my water give me my water kevin
i don't know
you think just just got to yell but it's
not that
oh christ
what the hell
gravity falls is much more mature
grunkle mel gibson he put the old in old
west they call him
grandpa the kid
i'm tired during the day
there's a bat in the kitchen i tried to
touch me with its weird little bad
fingers you always make me do dumb
chores i'm putting my foot down this
time i said do it kid now
[Music]
okay i'll do it
try harder dipper why doesn't he pick on
you guys dipper stan's personality is
one of life's great mysteries like
whether or not it's possible to lick
your own elbow i bet you can't but i
that can't possum triangulum and
tangulum ready for its dominus medium
many
foreign elbows
like the infinite horizon it eludes my
grass
nice
[Laughter]
this is satanic illuminati name's bill
cipher can i take it you're some kind of
living ventriloquist dummy
i'm just kidding i know who you are
gideon i know lots of things
[Music]
oh my oh gross
for you kid
what the hell you're insane sure i am
what's your point
the body horror episode i need you to
enter the mind of stamford pines and
steal the code to a safe i'll help you
with this and in return you can help me
with something i've been working on
we'll work out the details later d
deeked tales time to invade stan's mind
this should be fun remember reality is
an illusion the universe is a hologram
buy gold
dress like mr peanut
dipper oh you've got to help stan wait
what
so he's going to break understand's mind
or steal a combination to a safe also we
stop for snacks on the way here i want
burrito bites beware bill the most
powerful and dangerous creature i've
ever encountered
never let him into your mind
no what's happening if we don't do
anything gideon might steal the shot or
worse
fine get ready guys we're about to
journey into the most horrifying
disturbing
our uncle's mind
you think i could take these burrito
bites into stan's brain you know what
i'm just gonna bring him it's a valid
question what if you drop one follow
that dream demon into his mind the
dreamin
dentist omnium magistramentium magnesium
ad hominem
[Laughter]
magistramentium magistermentium
good latin salad there what have you
done oh wow
maybe it's a
big pile of money oh my god it's
terrifying we're in the slenderman game
remember everyone we've got to look out
for the triangle guy yeah
the triangle guy it's him it's the guy
you leave our uncle's brain alone you
isosceles monster
geometry ah stan's family we meet at
last question mark shooting star pine
tree i had a hunch i might bump into you
whoa
i even know what you're thinking right
now that's impossible no one can guess
what i'm thinking
whoa where are we bro we must be in
heaven cause i just saw an angel i've
never let it go if you like you're out
of your league yeah
we're going in
mabel can we leave those guys out here
looking at them hurts my eyes yeah
radical i also think it's radical cool
like bill and ted reefer
whoa it's like the night gallery let's
get searching jorge rico you're the two
best colombian prison friends a fella
could make espero que muera
see
stand back it sucks more than anything
got to work on that
[Laughter]
think of a way out
non-specific excuse
it's cold man it's cold we already know
how stan feels about us he loves us
we're great yeah let's just keep moving
oh don't leave the door open though
[Music]
[Laughter]
why you're so hard on dipper all the
time
look zeus i'm going to let you in on
something you want to know what i really
think i mean
the kid's a loser he's weak he's another
embarrassment
i just want to get rid of him
no
oh no
if only people knew the truth that
hidden behind this vending machine i
secretly
[Laughter]
damn it zeus if we want to find stan's
memory we gotta think like stan he's
always hiding stuff right yeah like how
he hides his arrest warrants under that
rug in the gift shop
oh
you're gonna lead him right to it 13 44
and finally
dude we found him let's just destroy the
door before bill can find it my big fat
arms are great at destroying stuff oh
okay
no
i knew you'd lead me straight to the
code
[Laughter]
it's funny how dumb you are
i work for stan day and night and all he
does in return is say he wants to get
rid of me dibber i'm sure that's not
true i saw it with my own eyes in one of
his memories mabel he's always picked on
me and now i know why stan hates me oh
dipper you're a cool dude but this isn't
cool dude
what have you unlocked
did you find the memory with the
combination yet relax short stack i got
it right here it's 13
44.
ah no no no wait no no more bottom
whatever that was it's gone forever
wait i'm switching to plan b
whoa
no
you have any idea what i'm like when i'm
mad
you're flaming hot dorito now
[Music]
oh my goodness
zardoz
he's weak i just want to get rid of him
yeah
those are all things people said about
me when i was a boy
oh no way you know at the time i thought
my pop was trying to torture me but
wouldn't you know it the old man was
doing me a favor all along get up there
left hook
i'm actually proud of him
just don't ever tell him that his head's
big enough as it is
that's true
oh
[Music]
let's fix that up
how'd you do that
word to the wise kid we're in the mine
you could do whatever you can imagine in
here
[Music]
oh my gosh what am i doing i gotta stop
bill
huh fighting back is he gonna remember
that later nightmare hope he doesn't
mean that british dog man i'm always
dreaming about
oh hello hello
who's quite for sticker departing
[Laughter]
no
[Laughter]
hey bill
what nice bow tie
dude guys i just learned that you can
conjure whatever you can conceive in
grunkle stan's mindscape
[Laughter]
who told you that don't listen to him we
can do anything
like have kittens for fists
yes
kitty guns
how
anything huh suslav stomach beam stare
steven souza
[Music]
verse and now to imagine your worst
nightmare a portal out of stan's mind
[Music]
no no no
enough
the void you're a lot more clever than
you look especially the fat one
he's talking about you
mm-hmm a darkness approaches a day will
come in the future when everything you
care about will change six fingers i'll
be watching you
[Music]
he's gone we did it
[Applause]
we did it
what did what
what are you all doing here and why was
i dreaming of too brightly colored and
radical young men
what is this a hug nope it's a chokehold
[Laughter]
not bad kid not bad
oh hell yeah group hog
no come on do it do it
hey do you guys feel it oh plan b
i've got the deed the mystery shack
belongs to me so get off my property
it's just part of the dream we're gonna
wake up any second now right right
no
hell no no wreck it ralph
that's a first really is getting real
this is so bleak i know they'll never
get it back
that was a great episode that was
terrific
that was
really uh
i'm listening
just that just just listening intently
okay i mean that was a ver i love the
trope of going into the personified mind
and
whether that materializes in
uh representation of like an office
building with a bunch of different you
know versions of whoever's mind it is
all running it or if it's more like this
where it's just like a gallery of
thoughts feelings and emotions uh you
know that's a it's a well-worn cartoon
uh you know episode idea but i really
enjoyed the way they did it here i
really loved that the in the inner
workings of stan's mind and i assume
anyone's mind in this uh
universe the show's universe would be
represented by this sort of yeah m c
escher-esque night gallery sort of thing
and i i was just so enthralled by that
plus
you know any time you're getting out
into the strange void of
you know illuminati conspiracy
mythological mumbo jumbo i i eat that
stuff up so this episode was this this
was
aimed directly at my head and i
appreciated that
what are your thoughts g
yeah i agree with the emcee hammer
uh
yeah the parachute pants all over that
was uh very uh
enthralled by
the
um illuminati
uh
website where you get good marvel news
yeah yeah yes i agree i'm right there
with you man yeah i thought that there
was so many
easter eggs about 411 thunder here this
is the clues to when the trailers come
in yeah
it'll be the day we were supposed to
post this yes
it
inevitably will be
um
yeah i thought this was great i i too
i'm a big fan of any of the stories of
diving into the mind
in a literal very exploratory
gob [ __ ]
like somehow cosmic yet esoteric sense i
i really
i don't know esoteric ethereal sense is
something that i really do like a lot i
think it's like beautiful to behold and
haunting and messed up and i thought it
was smart to keep it at a core of
of an emotional route with dipper and
this is one of the longer episodes too
to keep it at the core of dipper and
grunkle stan and then unpack why grunkle
stan is the way he is
to see that he wasn't just
born a douchebag that this a lot of it
is a veneer that he does do this with
the way to
you know put up a front that he is
tougher than he actually comes across to
develop natural strength over time but
underneath that is is truly a big softie
and someone who was a lot more like
dipper
than i would have even thought he would
like in his past he was that way too so
it was cool to
actually go to the past the way they
like structured it i thought was really
neat and of course like the
expressionism of this episode i thought
was also
quite beautiful it was funny
simultaneously
and uh i think the last couple episodes
have felt more like a real show
more than
ever
in terms of feeling like an actual story
with an ensemble and and again and like
a casper they all feel like essential
players you see what roles they all
serve
and this is the some of the best use of
gideon they've ever done too i think
that the way they've really utilized it
like it does feel like everything sort
of come together in this one episode
already even though the season's not
over it feels like in this particular
one all the weirdness
of gravity falls even with
pyramid mr peanut is what i said oh yeah
yeah
bill bill cipher is it bill cipher yeah
with even with bill cipher
like showing up be like gravity falls
how i missed you like he abused the
history and probably knows a lot more
the tease again that stan knows a lot
more too
that you know maybe by demolishing the
shack we'll probably uncover what's
finally inside the shack
it's like attack on titan if you guys
have seen it oh my god it's attack on
tied and the show ripped it off
and then uh
yeah which is with the with the cast
members themselves i i think this was
like probably the best one so far i
don't know if it's my personal favorite
but it's definitely up there is one of
the top ones because while i didn't find
it to be the funniest i thought it was
the sharpest and also the most
experimental without getting overly
bombastic uh i really enjoyed it a lot i
thought this was a great one really not
just i don't have any
criticisms with it whatsoever i thought
this was really really good and uh
managed to keep it dark but not go too
dark maybe dark when you're like you
know young kid or something that you're
like oh that's really dark
but um i don't know i feel like even as
a kid
it's not that dark it's probably not the
most scooby-doo to me in a lot of ways
too yeah yeah it's like the more surreal
iteration of a scooby-doo cartoon it's
like a sci-fi more sci-fi version yeah
absolutely the other ones
smoke
yeah and i mean it was fun to get the
the certain callbacks to like actual
moments from prior episodes whether that
be
actually stand going to the basement
being like yeah yeah they're not gonna
they're not gonna believe what i got
down here and also the bottomless pit
thing like i thought those were cleverly
used because yeah and the bottomless pit
it's like you know it could have been
whatever and now you're like oh dang
yeah that meant more than it seemed like
it did at the time
and it's things like that too that make
it feel more sort of yeah like a fully
fleshed out show world that continues
and grows as it goes
so uh yeah steady as she grows daddy as
she grows
new jack white yeah
[ __ ] fraud you're just right man
we're here to take them down
the el
levin nation army couldn't hold me back
[Laughter]
um yeah anyway guys uh
usually whenever something's just good
it's hard to really talk forever i
thought it was perfect this is a pretty
near perfect episode
yeah
i like the diving into the mind i think
it would be so cool to just spend more
time there yeah probably more twisted
probably more sexual too yes it would be
we would have to cross the birds and
bees border with the kids it wouldn't be
comfortable
but it might be important
you go to my mind it's just youtube
analytics
it's just charts and
it starts graphs
to me checking my phone for the browser
going through all social media there's
something come out that i missed
yeah
all right guys we'll see you soon let's
do a
page eric the horse
if there's anybody anybody whose mind we
would want to jump in to go jump in man
traverse your mind palace peer into your
deepest
darkest most sensual memories sensual
you're the guy i can't imagine what
would be in store for us what's inside
of that brain it would probably be a
little bit terrifying
pretty funny because you're waiting
probably be very charged and probably
see a litany of people you hate probably
people who i would be surprised to see
but moreover it would be the sexiest
mind we could possibly jump into you i
just imagined us all in leather for the
whole adventure remember you know just
like chaps not much else you know doing
our thing solving a mystery going burn
adventure saving you from having
somebody steal your most precious
information eric so hey man strengthen
your mind and step it up yeah because
you never know who's trying to break in
and steal what you got protect yourself
yeah don't wreck yourself we love you so
yeah yeah john loves you i love you
specifically me
be well eric horseman we'll see you next
month
in our dreams
[Laughter]
you will fight
[Music]